I was raised Catholic the thing that
used to annoy me about church when I was
little was all the standing up and
sitting down and kneeling I wish the
priest could just pick a position and
[__] me
no you're a Catholic and I'm a Jew and
Sammy you're black I'm sorry
I'm hanging in there no I mean it's uh
it's really well what are you doing what
are you doing do you do a lot I do
just like that do you use that use that
machine
is it a bird is it a plane whatever it
is it's heading straight for the World
Trade Center
will lead the conservatives into the
next election in the same way that
Muhammad Atta led a Boeing 747 into the
World Trade Center
far too soon
meanwhile FBI director Louis free said
this week that attorney general Janet
Reno might have a conflict of interest
in her investigation of democratic
fundraising free also pointed out that
Reno might have a conflict of interest
between her X and Y chromosomes
foreign
so how do you know when an idea is good
enough if you've never tried it out on
stage well there's a few different
there's some ideas I just know right
some ideas you just go because you've
been I've repeated the Rhythm so many
times being on the stage talking and
getting laughs right I'll have a thought
and I'll go oh that's that's a bit
because you know from all the years of
doing it yeah you just know and then
there's other bits things where I go I
don't think anyone I would ever like
this this is actually might be troubling
to some crowds I want to try it anyway
do you have give me an example if you
can think of one where you said to
yourself this could be really good but
it would be troubling to a crowd and
then you got up and it just totally like
the crowd was disturbed by it I mean I I
had one bit that never quite made it
because I didn't and I could have made
it work because you were having a dark
thought yeah it was dark yeah what was
the story well last year I did I think I
did this on the show actually on the
series I think I put it in there but it
was a thing about that uh you know
people hate child molesters so much they
hate them worse than murderers or
anybody else right right so getting
caught child molesting is just that's
the end that's the worst it's really the
end of your life in every way yeah
whatever you had is gone yeah right so
uh that's why a lot of kids that get
Melissa get killed because it's like
once you've whatever got you to the
moment where you molested a kid right
once you hit that moment you're like I
can't let this kid go now because I'm
[__] if this kid goes home and tells
anybody so you kill the kid right so the
bit was that if we could if we could
hate child molesting a little less
I get some kids back wow that is a
brilliant thought somebody could go
say to themselves all right I'm less you
know somebody could call you go hey I'm
molested your kid you want him back
after soccer or do you want me to drop
him off at this game doesn't he have any
allergies I should know about it so
we're hurting children by hating child
molesters so that's right well that's I
wasn't able to come to that conclusion
the way I made the bit work right for me
yeah and made it palpable for some
audiences like 20 right was to say I
don't I that what I just said is true
right that if we hated child molesters
less less children would die right I
don't know what to do with that
information
you don't know where to go I don't know
what to do with it I can't make it to
the right place today yeah so you're not
wearing a bra
really well that's good we're having a
good time already no we are I'm having
an excellent time although I'm wearing a
bra because
but I'm older than you yeah that's what
happens with age I I love I've had two
children I have had two children oh they
start to you need a little more help I
think mine were doing that before the
kids came along really
why are you rubbing my chair like this
is that is that a bond villain thing
you'd be a good bone villain actually I
think this is you know you so I'm
subliminally maybe doing what I whoa
this might be a
oh no he drives me in a bra it does let
me Flex let me Flags it's in Your Heart
Right Sam be proud Brothers we kiss we
hug uh any black on my lips
it's the rules it's it's how to capture
a man's heart and it it's for women and
it says all these rules that you have to
follow and you will capture a man's
heart and the rule number one have huge
breasts
[Laughter]
yeah that guy liked it
keeps calling me on the phone saying why
is that black guy getting them bigger
lines
I'm jealous but when you go to bed
tonight try to listen for a clock
George is getting smaller and smaller
tell him what you told me how you fed up
with the blacks and you don't want them
in your neighborhood
[Applause]
but we need the blacks without them to
be no Olympics
[Applause]
[Music]
here tonight
all right really
hardcore
no not hardcore you made your own
Christianity
yeah I mean I'm not busting on you
that's what people do they if you just
never heard of the Bible how old are you
32. no one you know ever heard of the
Bible you never heard of the Bible never
talked to you you were just walking
through a used bookstore today and
stumbled across the Bible like a Pioneer
little Lewis and Clark he's jumping
through it while you're taking a [__]
yeah you get you can read anything while
you're taking a [__] right
they put out okay let's say they put on
the back of [__] Captain Crunch how
about that
how quick how quick would you recognize
that as true would you go hey this is
exactly what I was looking for
yeah the flood and the Ark yeah this
sounds incredibly true you throw it in
the trash would you not if you've never
because that's why they have to pump it
into your head when you're still little
and you get a soft spot in your Santa
Claus eligible and they [__] bump it
all in there then you don't know any
better and then they cork it in there
with a whole bunch of fear and what you
do where you go I'm not a hardcore do
you make your own Christianity what your
brain does is it [__] you it's you
believe all the parts that don't affect
your life at all I believe in heaven I
believe Jesus and the resurrection yeah
sure sure but the parts that affect your
instincts directly which is your real
gone if you think about it
your [__] brain grows around not like
a club foot oh we have to adapt you no I
Believe In the Garden of Eden and all
that yeah oh oh pre-marital sex no I
think that was a typo that's opening too
but I believe in that
no I'm sure and yeah I love thy neighbor
to an extent except for that [__] head
up in 3B who plays Beastie Boys to four
o'clock in the morning
[__] dog if it doesn't stop barking
but but the Bible was written before
Beastie Boys are around so it's open to
interpretation
you don't believe it you don't
and this is how I know that those people
because every time you see a tragedy
whether it's 9 11 or a bus goes into a
lake or a [__] grandma spontaneously
combust whatever it is you see people on
the news and they have whining like
[__] and they got
it's horrible it's terrible and it's
trending
[Applause]
but at least these are the better play
style he's with Jesus
that's why are you crying why are you
trying to do with all your things your
depths of your soul believes that your
loved one is dancing around on a fluffy
cloud in an everlasting Paradise for all
of eternity without a care in the world
happier than pinworms and a baby's stool
why are you crying
static if you really believe it
either you call it all your friends on
the phone did you hear the great news
lightning struck my baby yeah he's in a
better place God picked him I told you
he was adorable
God's spirit of that average 72-year
sentence on this [__] planet
do you really believe that death leads
to Eternal Bliss and why are you wearing
a seatbelt
thank you